(Playing with some tissues)
I Did it! Hey guys I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop. Today
We're gonna be building a weapon that is quick, fun, easy,
and safe to use indoors. The supplies for this are super easy,
And there's a good chance you already have them lying around your house somewhere.
We’ll need two toilet paper rolls a pencil two rubber bands and some large marshmallows
We also have some tape and we're gonna use some of that for the build and some of it for decoration
Let's get started the first step is to take one of our cardboard tubes and with a pair of scissors
Cut it lengthwise now what we want to do is roll the tube a little bit tighter over on itself
We want to make the tubes small enough that a marshmallow can no longer fit down inside now with a piece of tape
Let's close our cardboard tube all along the seam
Our tube is now closed and taped shut
But it often tries to sort of pull away from the tape so to try and keep that from happening
Let's also take a little bit of tape on just the ends and tape that on the inside that should hold it together more securely
With the tube all taped up we now want to put two holes into the sides of it
Just large enough that we can fit the pencil through you can use a hole punch a drill or a knife to make those holes
There's our first now. Let's make the second hole directly across from that
Now we want to fit our pencil through one side of the hole and out the other however
We have kind of a bit more pencil than we need right here, so let's just trim this down
I'm gonna try and make it about
That long so that's going to be about cutting it in half
I'm kidding you don't need a chop saw to cut a pencil
Let's see how well we can get her a pencil with this pair of pliers
That was pretty easy let's see if we can use our exacto knife
I
Don't think I'm gonna be able to slice all the way through but I bet I can score the wood pretty well by rolling it
And then just snap it
That worked great see if we can get anywhere with scissors
Ha even scissors works
So there you go you do not have to use a chop saw to cut your pencil in half
We're gonna use this one. Just because all right so now
Let's get the pencil to fit through both sides of the hole so it's attached to our cardboard tube
There we go our pencils nice and secure
We now want to take our second tube and cut two notches into the top of it before we do that though
Let's run a layer of tape around there to give it a little bit of extra strength
I'm just gonna make two slits not even a centimeter long
About one centimeter apart just like that and they're gonna be on opposite sides of the tube
So we've got two little slits on this side now. Let's go to the opposite side and put two slits there as well now
Now we take our larger tube and place it over the top of our smaller tube
And then we'll need two rubber bands of the same size we want to fit our rubber bands around the notches
We just cut in the top of the tube
Now let's stretch our rubber bands down underneath the pencil and at this point we have a working marshmallow shooter
Load up our little confectionery treat drawback and fire
There is the very basic version of this marshmallow shooter. It works fairly well
It launches the marshmallows quite nicely. It's easy to carry around
It's easy to make it's very lightweight a lot of good things about it
But I think there are still a few improvements that can be made
To me the hardest part of this design is that it's kind of tricky to get a good grip on it
I guess you can try and use two fingers to pull back on the pencil
But if you have smaller hands that can be harder
And it's just a little awkward because you'll probably end up pulling you on one side more than the other
So I want to use some tape to make a tab that lets us pull straight back from the middle of the pencil
Let's start by taking the rubber bands off for just a second now. Let's tear off a strip of tape
That's a few inches long
but narrow enough that it can fit inside the smaller tube took my gloves off because
Anything with tape while you're wearing gloves is a pain
So let's take about an inch of this tape and feed it down into the tube and then
Secure it to the side of the pencil
now we can rotate the pencil and it should bring the side of our tape back up we can now pull it through and
stick the two sides together
Alright now we can reassemble our shooter and
We have a much more convenient pull tab to draw back on
(Wee) I wonder if I can get a shot where it hits the lens
Cameraman is taking all kinds of abuse right now
I'll count that that marshmallow shooter works pretty well and our upgrade of the pull handle
I think makes a big difference
But I still want to try upgrading one more time and that's to a larger size so instead of using toilet paper tubes
Paper towel tubes. These are a lot longer
We've got some longer rubber bands, and I'm hoping we can get more of a long distance shooter
But the process will be just the same, so we'll start by cutting one of these tubes lengthwise
We attach the rubber bands to the notches of the top, and then we stretch them down over the pencil below
Now we have a marshmallow shooter with a lot longer draw
Let's do the same process we did before to add the little pull tab on the back and then decorate this a little bit
Just to make this pull-tab a little bit easier to hold on to let's cut off a small piece of pencil and then wrap tape
Around it that should give us something that we can grip more easily
There we go
Look like a sniper
One on one shot two on the next shot. I don't think I can take the top three nope
With your marshmallow launchers built it's time to have fun set up some targets knock over some cups shoot your friends. It's just marshmallows
They're not really gonna hurt much
This is a quick and easy build and like I said before there's a good chance you already have all the materials at your house
Already if not they're cheap and easy to get your hands on
Hey guys. Thanks for watching if you're not a subscriber yet
Just hit the bomb to get in the club if you missed our last video or want to watch it again
Just click up here at the top click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks that you should watch next
That's it for now. Have fun. Be safe and see you tomorrow